hey everyone dfolo here and in today's video we
are going over the next Arc in gigayakotami's
mental mind trip of a story that is Jujutsu
Kaizen this perfect variation Arc is actually
peak gigay writing as it starts to kick things off
in terms of the killing game and gives us way more
of an understanding with how things are going
to go down throughout Earth the amount of new
characters abilities and just pure freaking hype
is amazing let the girls go so damn hard in this
Arc it's just too good now obviously enough of me
creaming over father gigay and his holy scriptures
obviously if you are new around here I Want More
Story type explain content just like this then be
sure to hit that subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like on the video as it really
helps out with pushing my stuff to a bunch of
new amazing people anyway sit back and relax
as we dive straight back into Juju Kaizen so a
quick reminder to everyone is that obviously this
Arc literally picks up with things finished right
at the end of the last one with Yuji Yuta migami
and all of them in a conversation over the Cullen
game and the implications around it with migumi's
sister having been revealed to be caught up in the
Cullen game for shikoro like the best friend he
is tells Yuji to let go of his past mistakes the
things he can't control to instead help save his
sister now thinking of it as grandfather's final
words Yuji comes up with a compromise he instead
asks Yuta to kill him in the event that sakuna
should ever take over his body again YouTube
believes that the big man akotsu is stocky enough
to be able to take him down to which the second
year agrees saying that he'll do what he can so
after the agreement migami lays out the plan to
them they first need to contact tingen and find
out how to actually unseal Gojo and what Brian
kun's objectives truly are the game itself is
a form of Jujutsu terrorism on a scale that has
never been seen before and migami believes that
they need answers to ever mention questions Yuji
asks if Yuki would know to watch migumi reveals
that this was her idea and obviously this goes to
prove that instead of the higher-ups like I said
in the previous video it was actually Mega me
that she was you know in contact with a tune that
Yuki is hiding at jiju high currently and waiting
for them while try to avoid the higher-ups there
Yuda goes on to say that there is a problem with
contacting tingen due to the recent events back in
the Gojo past Arc tingen's concealing barrier is
active and shuffles over 1 000 doors continuously
with only one leading to him Yuji interrupts and
asks what the situation with nobara is but only
gets an encouraging saddened look as a response
from his boy trying to contain his emotions Yuji
leans over and also looks to the ground while
repeating I get hurt chosu who I somehow forgot
to mention was still around because he's my boy
it probably makes it known that he may know a way
past Yuji asks what he means and chosen reminds
them on how mahiso had stolen some of sukuna's
fingers in death paintings from Jujutsu and the
past then goes on to say that he thinks he can do
the same thing skipping forward all four of the
boys which by the way like what a freaking go to
the group right here they all into this school in
secrets and mix with Yuki and Mahi inside seeing
Maki for the first time since Shibuya it's obvious
that she's visibly taken a freaking baiting
from a fight with jogo and Dagon there even
after shoku's reverse curse technique her body is
still severely mutilated concerned for her Yoda
goes up to Marquee and asks if it's okay for her
to be moving seeing this though Yuki explains to
him that a reverse curse technique can't actually
prevent scars from Burns Mikey was literally only
able to survive jogo's Flames because of the
physical durability granted to her through her
Heavenly restriction Maki then asks Mecca me about
their plan to slip past the concealing barrier
choso like the big Pro years volunteers to inform
the group and explains that between the correct
door and the tomb is a cursed Warehouse where his
brothers are currently being stored his connection
to them will allow him to guide everyone to
the correct door Maki is satisfied with the
plan but she needs clarification on who exactly
choso is after a brief silence Yoshi reluctantly
tells everyone just to think of choso as his big
brother for now which like oh my Lord choso must
have had like fireworks go off inside of his head
or something like even in reality he's visibly
shocked and excited to finally hear that Yuji is
saying his name skipping forward chosu guides the
group to the correct door confident that his
brothers sleep Beyond it Yuji is surprised to
find that there is no solar path Beyond the Doors
just a massive drop into a forested area filled
with tall old trees after Yuki tells them to move
forward and searches the elevator the group walks
past a warehouse which also stops for a moment he
reluctantly touches the door and asks his brothers
to just wait a little longer for him to return and
save them honestly I want to make shoso who's one
of either choso's brothers or sisters I feel like
it's going to be a goated female version of choso
like honestly we just we gotta have her in the
series as well if chosa was this cool after the
group takes the elevator down to the Tomb of the
star Yuki notices blood stains on the ground and
asks what happened Yuki says that it's the remains
of when everything in the Jiu Jitsu World began to
distort even picturing the demon himself for
shiguro in her mind after a moment Yuki moves
on and leads them directly to the main Shrine and
once there they walk into nothing but a completely
stark white void with everyone confused Yuki
says tingen is currently rejecting them normally
The Entity doesn't interact with the world but
Yuki thought contact may have been possible now
that Gojo has been sealed she also considers the
possibility that tinken isn't rejecting everyone
and instead just tour this is you know obviously
just due to the fact that she has her own agenda
and in some ways wouldn't mind knocking off all
of the higher-ups Just Like Gojo unsure of what
to do Yuda tells everyone that they should head
back since migami's sister doesn't have time to
waste suddenly a voice rings out and asks why are
they all leaving so soon the thumb of an entity
then appears Master tingen finally reveals himself
while saying it's a pleasure to meet the children
of the Xenon family machizane's descendant which
I I really hope I didn't botch because it always
sounds so freaking weird in my head the death
painting womb and finally sukuna's vessel while
everyone else is surprised by tingen's thumb-like
shape Yuki asks why tingen didn't address her in
their greet him Tegan replies that this isn't
the first time they've met Yuki's next question
is why the Tomb of the star was closed to which
it's revealed tingen is unable to see into the
human heart and feared that Yuki was aligned with
kinjaku finally like oh my God I can stop calling
him by the 900 names I keep giving him as it's
explained through tingen here that hinjaku is
the real name of the body switching entity that
was once known as narutoshi kamo and now inhibits
the body of suguru gito Yuji like the absolute
melon he'd hears Cuts in on the conversation to
ask why tingen look so freaking weird while mikumi
stands there surprised with Yuji tenkin explains
that even though his curse technique grants a
form of immortality it's not anti-aging 11 years
ago when the star plays my vessel failed tingen's
aging process accelerated and the self-awareness
it had as an individual diminished therefore
it was forced to evolve and now technically has
become one with the world itself which is a lot
to take in and has so many implications in this
story they have like even yet to be explained
like what even is this Evolution he was meant
to go through like why was it considered bad
in the Gojo past Arc if it didn't assimilate
when now he can still control the barriers and all
of that kind of stuff anyways anyways mikimi and
yuto get to the point and ask about kinjaku's
objectives along with unsealing Gojo from the
prison realm tingen goes on to say that he will
provide information on one condition at least two
of the three people prison did a special grade
must remain at the Tomb of the star to serve
as guards since the lot are kind of confused as
to why tinken explains that King jaku wants to
force the evolution of all of the people in Japan
but he can't do this while tenkins barriers are
active because that requires an insane amount of
cursed energy starting an evolution of that scale
using the cursed technique is utterly inefficient
instead the Mythic kinjaku has chosen as to merge
tengen with mankind itself since evolving into
this new state it is now possible for tingen
to merge with someone who isn't the star place
for vessel any human who merges with the tingen
evolves into something Beyond a sorcerer that is
both there and not part of the Physical Realm at
the same time tinken stabilized and maintains
self-control even after evolving thanks to the
barrier techniques but says the world would end if
anyone merges with him it's explained that there
would be no boundaries between individuals and
the impurities of millions of humans would flood
the entire world what happened to Tokyo would
engulf the entire planet resulting in any world
of cursed Spirits what's actually insane is that
tingen also can't refuse the merger because the
failed assimilation has caused them to turn into
more of a curse Spirit than a human being which
is obviously a perfect Target for someone with
curse manipulation so kinjaku's plan is finally
revealed Honestly though like the amount of time
it must have gone into this plan and sitting upper
in preparation and getting all the people that
he needs to get it must have been absolutely
freaking mental anyways due to the threat of
kinjaku coming to unseal the tomb the corridor
is rejecting everyone that approaches hence you
know like the white room King Jacob was the one
who set the plan in motion they'd stop the merger
11 years ago it was also involved with sukuna over
a thousand years ago to which Yuki wonders why is
he making a move just now it said that the tingen
star plays my vessel and six eyes are connected
by Fate kinjaku has been defeated by two different
success users in the past and after a second
defeat he managed to kill the star plasma vessel
and the next six size user the day after they were
born yet despite all of these efforts they still
somehow appeared on the day of the merger what
tingen being left at a dead end made him switch
to the method of sealing the six eyes instead of
attempting to eradicate it completely however an
eternal fate that neither tingen or kinjaku
ever expected 11 years ago the Heavenly gifted
demon toji fushiguro intervened a man who escaped
curse energy entirely and therefore was not bound
by the chains of Fate that affected the Jujutsu
World an effect told you destroyed the Destinies
that bound tingen the star plasma vessel and the
six eyes then along with toji came Suga dugito a
boy who just happened to be able to manipulate
cursed Spirits then after what could have been
a thousand years worth of research hinjaku secured
the prison realm six years ago and all his plans
fell into place so in all actuality this game is a
ritual to really the people of Japan for a massive
merger with tingen it uses the player's curse
energy and the barriers to transfer everyone to
the other side through the these weird veil-like
Customs Tinker can be forced to merge with all of
humanity in order to pull off something of this
level kinjaku has restricted himself with these
binding vowels one stipulates that he is not the
game master so even killing him will not end the
game instead the only way that it can end is once
all of the players are dead and there are rules
in place to ensure that nothing can interrupt the
original ritual the other best possible course of
action for them would be to expend 100 points to
add rules when migumi's sister and others who are
unwilling to participate can escape the game free
and Saturday Gojo would also be extremely ideal
but before tenkin reveals how they're able to do
this it requires the group to pick two of them to
serve as guards they are like big thumb drop in
a truckload of freaking insane information that
changes the entire landscape of the world like
it truly goes to show how much time and effort
has gone into this plan on kinjaku's side even
now if he dies his plan is still in place and he
expects that he will come out top no matter what
following this Yuki and choso volunteer themselves
as choto knows Yuji will need you this help and
this will also give him a chance to protect his
brothers shukinjaku comforting In Here yuhi Also
isn't finished talking with tingen either way and
would like to stay back if that's meant with
the others wanting to be around everyone else
you happily agrees with the plan after thanking
them tingen then proceeds to take out the back of
the prison realm explaining that it is a separate
cursed object that will be necessary and unsealing
Gojo after hinjaku found the front he had the bag
back in jaku now Bears complete authority over
their prison realm as the bearer of the front gate
and can block them from accessing the bag breaking
it open is instead the only way and would require
curse tools they can cancel cursed techniques like
the inverted Spirit of heaven or the black robe
however both of those were lost in secret battles
with Gojo so like obviously for those who don't
know what these are it's the blade that toji used
in his fight with Gojo 11 years earlier in the
Gojo past Arc and the black rope that Miguel used
against Gojo during the night parade of a hundred
demons and introduced to Kaizen zero but you know
anyways anyways in an attempt to look for more
of like that rope user had already been searching
in Africa with Miguel but sadly to no avail as it
takes centuries for them to create something like
it however there is still one way to get into
the back of the prison realm a thousand years
ago there was a female sorcerer who called herself
Angel she possessed a cursed technique that could
extinguish others curse techniques pretty much
nullifying them her name is Hannah kurosu and
she's been incarnated as a culling game player
honestly this character poses so much of like
a curveball to the game why is kinjaku decided to
also revive or bring back this sorcerer what's the
specifications around her coming back and being
a part of this game there has to be some like
reasoning behind it allowing someone who would
like pose a threat to the Integrity of the game
to come back and participate in the first place
seems kind of wet you know tingen repeats that
Angel's technique will be necessary to open the
back of the prison realm with everyone confused
making me asks where Angel is and tenkin can
only say that she is in the colony on the east
side of Tokyo it is then shown that there are 10
colonies that are connected by barriers that form
a line down Japan this line of barriers will merge
everyone in Japan with a tingen and transfer them
to the other side Hokkaido isn't actually included
because it's already been established as a sacred
area there has been assimilated which is like what
do you mean by that as Hokkaido reminiscent of
ancient Japan in regards to the curse spirits and
fights that are currently going on there anyways
anyways this whole mental idea of evolving
Humanity by merging the watingen's current
state is extremely complex and sounds somewhat
exaggerated however this is only a testament to
how serious the situation actually is thinking
their reveals that a curse head in sacred merged
with every single person in Japan in preparation
for the merger and believes it will now only take
about two months to fully complete the ritual the
group then goes over the rules of the Cullen game
once again the first rule states their players
must declare their participation at any colony
of their choice within 19 days currently it's 9
A.M on the 9th of November and all players have
awakened their curse techniques around midnight
on the 31st of October which was when kinjaku
initiated the Countrywide idle Transfiguration
this only gives migami's sister 10 days and 15
hours to declare participation in the culling game
this second rule states that anyone who breaks the
first rule will be subject to curse technique
removal Marky had previously talked with shoko
about this rule of the game believing the acoustic
removal implies that it's not through idle
Transfiguration or a binding vowel but instead she
thinks that it must be something that must happen
to the user's brain which would in turn kill them
as if it was a vow all players could simply refuse
participation tinken confirms shoko's theory
meaning that people like Maki who currently
don't even possess cursed energy are actually at
a risk of dying rule number three explains that
anyone who enters a colony after the games have
begun will be considered an official participant
civilians and said the barriers will be given
one chance to exit and there are currently no
rules about entering or exiting colonies when the
game starts players will be given an incentive to
move towards the colony excerpts this serves as an
incentive to stimulate participation as in order
to confine players effectively they must believe
they entered the games of their own free will
the fourth rule was the one that states players
score points by killing one another the fifth
one specifies that each player's points value is
determined by the game master currently Sorcerers
are worth five points and non-sorcerers are worth
one having just heard of this game master tingen
explains to them that each player receives a
shikagami known as cocaine this creature serves
as the game's interface while the game master
serves as the program that runs it in some way
obviously this concept is super confusing as
gike is on his Astro [__] like even Yuji is
lifting a comically lost State rule 6 states that
players can spend 100 of their own scored points
to negotiate a new role in the game these rules
can't be subtracted but migami thinks they might
be able to create other rules as roundabout ways
to counter the original ones without disrupting
the game in accordance with rule 6 rule 7 states
that the game master must accept any new rule as
long as it doesn't have a long lasting effect on
the game the group wonders if the rules of fear
buttingen assures them they can Joker receives no
bias towards himself with these rules and they can
expect to be treated fairly just like any other
player the eighth and final rule states that a
player will be subject to curse technique removal
if this score does not change for 19 days this
causes you to worry about whether or not he'll
have to kill others but again Mega me suggests
that he might have a few ways around that with
all the information thoroughly reviewed Marky
then begins to go over everyone's role Yuki and
choso will remain at the Tomb of the star while
will return to the zening clan to collect the
missing curse tools now that Mega me is the
zening Clans leader Marky will be able to use this
to her advantage to get them Maki then inquires
about the location of Joseph kamiya's Workshop
what she will go to before recruiting Panda to the
group this juuzo dude in his Workshop is the guy
that gakuganji fought and the one that Gojo later
absolutely mangled like broke all those limbs they
must have interrogated him for the location of his
Workshop where he made all his weird ass tools and
stuff anyway you will instantly take part in the
Cullen game to gather information long performing
sister and the others have to join Yuji will try
to avoid nearby colonies to prevent collateral
damage in case something happens but because of
this he might be out of touch since the barriers
likely block phone reception he quickly realizes
this presents an issue as Yuji asks Yuta to kill
him should sakona ever appear again they both
think for a moment until migami says that Yuda can
just kill Yuji if he dies first but Yuji wants to
try prevent migami's death in the first place
Maki tells yuchi and migami that their role is
to find Hikari Kenji the suspended third year
and to recruit him to their group despite his
Moody attitude akari is apparently insanely tough
with you to go in as far as to say that when he's
riled up hakaris passes everyone even him in
strength after this everyone finally moves out
but not before Yuji thanks choso for everything
he has done so far and while he waves goodbye
his big bro tells him to not go dying on him
out there meanwhile at probably a similar time
in a random comedy club called the public stand
everyone sits around bored with an act that's
obviously bombing on stage like the man visibly
sucks ass at comedy his name anyway turns out
to be fumuhiko takaba his mate tells the 35 year
old takaba to quit because he's simply not cut out
for the job this massive Japanese dude who just
happens to be in the corner says he doesn't mind
his dumb jokes he thinks there are two types
of of comedians who will always be in demand
Comics who are funny and Comics who wholeheartedly
believe that they are funny kin who's the mess of
Japanese dude asks takaba which of the two he
believes he is takaba says it's 50 50 at first
before receiving a strange impulse then deciding
to change his answer to 70 30. well well hasn't an
Army's technique revived itself and someone else
I don't know just a thought I love the idea that
it could possibly be The Reincarnation of nanami's
technique or at least I hope it is anyway skipping
back to a moment shortly after Panda's Birth
masamichi has seen confined in his cell with
both of his hands bound it's explained through
gehukanji that it's normal for a curse corpse
to operate independently as they usually consume
cursed energy provided by its user in comparison
panda is a self-supporting cursed corpse that can
generate his own cursed energy pretty much like
the man literally created life itself because
of of us the higher-ups were in the process of
designating him as a special grade and actually
imposing him with an indefinite restraint after
stating this to him Goku ganji asked how Panda was
made but masamichi insisted that he didn't know
now in the present Yaga is only run but chilling
only forest with one of his dolls the curse corpse
is able to talk and calls out to masamichi saying
everyone is worried about how gloomy he's become
masamichi pets his head and reveals that he won't
be able to return anytime soon adding that Master
team can protects the forest they are currently
hiding in after saying he'll be fine on his own
they head over to a tree where Yaga opens a small
door inside many of his small harmless independent
cursed corpses reside knowing that they will never
see him again they tell him they will all miss him
meanwhile and so the isolation holding chamber
executes you high kuzukabe uses his Katana to
cut Panda free he goes on to say that he is doing
this as a favor to repay masamichi but make sure
or to tell Panda to not reveal who helped him
flashing back to the past once again we learn
they must admit she created an independent
cursed corpse with kusakabe's nephew's Soul
information kusakabe's sister had lost his
son and couldn't live on without the support
that he was providing her one day when she was
brought to Yaga a small dog-like doll asked if
that woman was his mother then goes on to say
he's a genius after being confirmed right by
Yaga kuzakabe's sister immediately recognizes
her son's mannerisms and instantly darts out
of her catatonic state to embrace him after the
two console each other masamichi explains that
he couldn't allow takuru which is the real child's
name like not the doll but like the real child to
live with his mother as he couldn't risk a getting
out that a fully independent curse corpse existed
even still kusakave apologized and emotionally
expressed his gratitude towards masamichi for
doing so by the way this whole moment it just
happened was actually before Panda was even born
I forgot to mention that but it probably makes a
bit more sense on how the fact that no one knew
an independent curse corpse existed at the time
back in the present day Yaga is confronted by
an unknown sorcerer he asks where masamichi is
going without any of his cursed corpses to back
him up while removing his jacket like the freaking
absolute Beast he is the principal simply replies
that he is going to see his son this sorcerer
is left slightly confused as he doesn't know
what masamichi means but goes on to explain the
severity of the current situation the principal
finds himself in he says the only way to save
himself now is to reveal how to create independent
cursed corpses immediately asimichi says that
his adversaries have gotten comfortable getting
pushy without Gojo around to which these sorcerer
agrees especially as he's been accompanied by a
veteran sorcerer On Cue yakuganji suddenly steps
out of his shadows and Deals masamichi a fatal
blow to his chest shattering the electric guitar
and leaving him mortally wounded with two deep
cuts across his front forming an x-shape that
also split his blood alongside the wall Jacob
tells the sorcerer accompanying him to leave the
two principles alone then with his last words
masamichi suddenly begins explaining exactly how
to create independent cursed corpses he states
that his Soul's information can be replicated
from physical information and imported into
cursed Corpse's cause these cores must contain
three highly compatible Souls which are always
observing each other this is the only way Souls
will stabilize and give rise to self-awareness
and self-sustaining cursed energy confused and
shocked by all of us dakuganji asks why masamichi
will tell him now instead of trying to live by
revealing this earlier just then before passing
away must meet your replies that it's a curse
being passed on from him tokokuganji instantly
after Panda arrives only moments too late just as
masamichi dies kakuganji throws down the broken
remains of his weapon in anticipation for panda
to retaliate however Panda simply walked straight
past them towards masamichi without so much as
ever glancing Edgar ganji confused he asks why
panda doesn't fight but Panda reveals that he's
not like humans and their behaviors do not blind
him he understands that kakuganji was on good
terms with masamichi and these orders probably
came from the higher ups even so pandas sheds
a tear for his father and tells the koganji
to remember that even pandas cry which is just
like too damn sad man recent peace big musumichi
absolute go anyway anyway now we skip away to the
absolute brutality that happens over at the Zenon
household I call my Lord you guys are not ready
for what is about to happen if you have not seen
this moment you are going to literally freak it is
so good our girl oh let's get into it so in order
to fulfill her role in helping with the culling
game Marky returns to a place where she's never
felt welcome as she enters these Indian household
to collect the curse tools she's immediately
greeted by the misogynistic neo-year seeing how
scarred she is now he taunts her as he believes
or Maki head was your attractiveness and now that
it's gone he asks if he should mercilessly bully
her like he used to in the past he continues to
throw abuse towards our girl however she just
ignores his crude ass and heads on underground
after the scene in some of the stairs into the
underground Corridor Maki finds her mother
awaiting her there she reminds her daughter
that they cannot enter the warehouse to which Maki
like the boss she has nonchalantly holds up their
keys while saying that Mega me is the new hit of
the clan and gave her permission and he flashback
we find out that Marky was actually the person who
revealed to Mega me that he had become the head of
the clan heavily reluctant with the idea of being
head making me suggest that he let Maki take over
for him instead but she denies the option as she
knows no one would accept her she points out that
he's inherited visiting Clans prized tin Shadows
technique and achieved its domain expansion Mega
me really didn't want to take the role as head
and asked if things like acceptance mattered
if she becomes a clan here she would still get
the race sources but Maki doesn't believe she's
good enough to make this home a place where my
belongs not yet once Maki said that about her
sister migami finally understood in the present
as Marky cruises past her mother she suddenly
screamed at by her to stop and instead come back
maki's mother asks why her daughter is always like
this and tells her to at least make her mother
proud once for giving birth to her however Maki
just completely ignores her pleas and continues
on until she finds a door that seals the cursed
Warehouse after using the key to unseal the chains
holding their doors together Maggie finally enters
however she's instantly shocked to see her father
unexpectedly sitting inside of the room without
a single curse tool in sight marky's father who
was another of the misogynistic lot reveals that
he anticipated marky's move and emptied out all
of the curse tools beforehand he stands up and
reveals mice injured body behind him Mai seen
Mikey there for the first time calls her it for
coming which is really random when you put it in
that context meanwhile junichi meets with naoya to
filament on these circumstances jinichi explains
anayo that Megami is the better choice for the
clan head because of his good relationship was
set at a Gojo and narutoshi kamo at the same time
jinichi refuses to allow an outsider to inherit
the entire Fortune naioya asks why they don't
just get rid of him but then you need she explains
that they can't do that killing migumi outright
will hurt these inning Clan standings with the
other Gojo and kamo Clans and they would fall
behind in the power vacuum left behind by Saturday
asks why they're doing it now if that's the case
engineer she explains that they're going to take
advantage of the notice from Jujutsu headquarters
it's explained there through them that it's been
deemed a crime to unseal Saturn Gojo so this
inning Clan is going to execute migami Maki and
Mai as Rebels plotting to do so now he is amused
by the plan and while killing his own daughters
will boost ogi's credibility know your wonders if
he is actually okay with the idea to which as the
battle begins between father and daughter junichi
reveals to naoya that this plan was originally
ogi's idea which just goes to show like how [__]
up this inning Clan is and how old all of their
thoughts are like look at the house the woman
the men the clothes like literally everything
it's it's time to move forward zinnon Clan you
just you guys just do not get it like don't get me
wrong I actually love it because that's the whole
point of the sect in a way to make you hate the
group while still wanting to know more about all
of them especially naoya like that dude has just
reading absolutely perfectly back as the battle
starts off Okie activates his falling Blossom
emotion he explains that he kept Mai alive as a
bargaining chip in case Marky arrived with any
unknown curse tools that cause in an emergency
situation Marky wields juuzou's Masterpiece
the goated curse tool dragon bone its effect or
ability I guess is that after accumulating cursed
energy the user can inject it out the back of the
way to increase its cutting power Mikey plans
to take advantage of ogi's ignorance and bait
entering a single strike Jewel while actually
intending to hit back multiple times just before
indemny's standoff Augie asks why Mikey thinks
neobito was chosen over him as head of the clan
Mahi asks if it's because he's a terrible person
willing to kill his own children which instantly
prompts Okie to start the fight as Okie darts
forward she blocks his first slash and follows up
with an attack of her own utilizing the momentum
granted by cursed energy shooting out the back of
the blade oh he tries to Parry but quickly notices
his katana blade is actually broken allowing Marky
to get behind him and go for the finishing blow
however with some unrealistically fast tie me
from an old timer Okie quickly spins around
and counters for this blazing curse technique
momentarily solidifying his blade before he cuts
Maki down Mikey's already busted eye as a game
Hit and cuts open along with her lower abdomen
which was sliced through from the attack left
definitely injuries Maki doesn't understand what
happened until she realizes that Oogie's blade
has been replaced by the Flames of his cursed
energy as she falls defeated Okie shoots a tear
and reveals he couldn't become head of the clan
because his children are indeed worthless man I
like I said I hate this in family's ideology and
like Jujutsu in general like if you wanted your
kids to improve you would teach them techniques
and not treat them like absolute ass all the time
that's not Marky who's the failure on this like
situation Mr ogisan it was your failure as a hero
to teach your children correctly and guide them
and now it is time to pay the consequences as
Ogie drags his twin daughter's bleeding bodies
down a corridor leaving a trail of their blood
behind him he explains why Marquee lost he says
that she stepped in close and treated her opponent
like his swordsman and not a sorcerer who repeats
that he did not become head of the clan because of
the quality of his children naobito's projection
sorcery technique doesn't have much of a history
outside of passing it down to na oh yeah so this
was not a determining factor and a choice the
only difference between them was how strong
their children turned out to be Oggy states
that children must not hold back their parents and
tosses his daughter down a flight of stairs like
the trash he thinks they are into an empty large
room he explains this area is for training and
discipline a plethora of curse Spirits are
kept fear they will eat the twins as soon as
Ogie leaves he mocks Marky and claims her Heavenly
restriction is nothing compared to other sorcerers
who trained and reinforced their muscles with
curse energy every single day for years on end
her father then turns his back on his daughters
and says farewell to the stains of his life one
final time before the curses move in Mai is able
to sit up and puts marky's head on her lap as she
feels Mark is heart beating she knows how tough
her twin truly is okay I used to hate Mai but like
really in this moment right here it fully changed
my total outlook on her I always thought that she
was just another of the Xenon household content
with the way things are and that's why she was
always a [__] towards Marquee but right now we
find out that Mai suspected that this would happen
someday and is ready to do what is necessary to
save her sister she opens marky's mouth and says
this sucks before breathing the life back into
her suddenly Marky awakens somewhere on a beach
as if she's been rescued from drowning which is
like so cute literally like she breathed the ear
back into her after drowning in the crap from her
family like it's such a great analogy right here
from Giga she's laying next to Mai who explains
that she's going to use a construction technique
to make something but will then die from this
strange due to the injury she's already sustained
Mike gets up in his sand and walks into the water
or saying goodbye and washing her twin good luck
in life this greatly confuses Marquee who gets up
and begs her sister to come back Mai explains that
she knew for a while that twins are a bad Omen
for Sorcerers to gain one must give however that
rule doesn't always apply to twins because curse
energy treats them as One Singular entity even
if Marky wants to get stronger she can't because
why doesn't so it was sad and as messed up as it
is as long as Maya's around Marky can never fully
develop in an attempt to get her sister to stop
Maki tells her that she understands but she still
doesn't want to lose her sister and runs after her
asking for her to come home again Mike stems her
hand to Marky telling her that she is only going
to leave her one thing so make sure to throw the
rest away my will take away all of the acoustic
energy when she dies so in return she asks Maki
to promise her just one thing destroy everything
Market takes a small read from her sister's
hand and reflects on the time they were happy
as children and the next moment hell itself has
returned as Marky awakens in reality noticing that
she's holding a sword handle instead of a reed
and a moment of beauty she's being protected by
her sister who has tragically topbled over her
with no more Life Lift a new body overwhelmed
by emotion Mahi cries out and tells Mai to wake
up while a bunch of curse Spirits Rush up behind
her skipping over to the old man as he walks away
he notices something that just doesn't feel right
and turns around to see what's up Suddenly all of
the cursed Spirits are exercised instantaneously
confusing Okie as their presences just vanish for
him okay like remember our girl is now outputting
zero NADA none literally no curse energy at all
in her staff it's just them pure gains time to
see what really pays off physical strength through
training your entire life occur strength ogi oh he
readies his Katana and says Marky strolling
through the Shadows of the doorway before
she gently places Mai's body down Oogie's body
begins to trample with fear as he knows his mind
has tried its best to forget this feeling Mucky
emerges from his shadows and instantly reminds
him of no one other than a demon Warrior who
possessed no cursed energy the breaker of Fate
himself poji Xenon struck with a jolt of fear
Okie immediately activates his curse technique
blazing courage causing his katana's Broken Blade
and scorching Flames that blaze a circle around
him with his scorching blade pointed at Mahi Ogie
threatens to burn his worthless child to the bone
in a fight to the death however before he could
even finish talking Marty like the freaking Beast
she's always being effortlessly decapitates his
head while walking past him in fact I don't even
know how much of a specific buff this was like
we have to get big old broken Ronin on it or
something but the slash was so damn fast that okay
he never even saw it coming Maki stops behind her
father's defeated corpse as it falls to the ground
she looks at the last gift my gave her then ready
to keep her promise gripsley cursed tall in her
hand and tells Mai it's time to get started time
to start the absolute destruction that is about
to happen like oh I can't wait literally like as
an alarm bell sounds out notifying the zidden clan
janichi and naoya leave their mating room and go
into a hallway young Ranter zinan finds them and
tells jinichi that Maki has gone mad and actually
killed Okie which leaves the others completely
surprised so since these inning Clan is like just
freaking massive they have a variety of different
groups consisting of people with varying skill
levels one of these is the 50-man kukuru unit that
gets dispatched to apprehend Marquee following
in the [__] ass way of every Zen and male this
Captain nobuwagi Zenon tells his men that she must
have killed Ogie in his sleep or in the bathroom
obviously it's severely under estimating her
stream this kukuru unit is made up of Xena men who
do not manifest enemy technique but are still able
to use cursed energy they end up fighting Maki in
the cursed Spirit Room and Surround her with at
least 20 men from the unit standing there alone
looking like the complete hellhound where the
dragon bone in one hand and Mai's Creation in the
other Marquee can only think about her sister she
wonders what her plan was and if she should really
have given up on becoming a sorcerer alongside my
she figures that that might have been the right
answer all along and apologizes to her sister
for potting her through all of the pain that she
did from around her the 20 kukuru unit Fighters
all attack or Mahi remembers Mai's final request
destroy everything Mikey opens her eyes just as
one of the men attempts to slash her instantly
and on some freaking Matrix level [__] she
avoids the blade and cuts off both of the man's
hands in one fluid motion then vaults over his
back and cuts down several of his allies before
5 finally be hitting the fodder fall below her
despite their numbers the kukuru units frankly
nothing compared to the now unrestricted Marty
who effortlessly kills one after another and
successively brutal fashion oh my Lord I love
this fight like the look on everyone's freaking
face as she's just annihilating them as perfect
this absolute egg novawaki arrives back somehow
expecting Maki to actually have been finished off
already yet as he stroll certain he's unpleasantly
surprised to see that all of his men have been
turned into bloody corpses by an unscathed Marquee
suddenly our new beloved icon of female strength
notice as a surge of cursed energy nearby coming
from chojiro zinin instantly she's tossed flying
up into the ear by a pair of gigantic stone hands
the then attempt to smash her while she's falling
back down to earth nobody recognizes this attack
as chojodo's curse technique and note that the hey
have now arrived which by the way is a group made
up of only the strongest comprised of everyone in
the family with a semi grade 1 or higher ranking
so now the proper fight begins this stone hands
aren't enough to hold Marky as she tears her way
back out novawaki and chojiro attempt to stop
her but she jams her hands into their throat at
blinding speed literally killing them both before
they could even react Ryan to watching this loses
his paralyzing technique to try and hold Maki in
place while yelling for janichi to hurry up and
finish her off while jinichi Sprints in to kill
her Maki fights back and forcibly breaks out
of ranta's technique this literally sends his
technique back at him or something similar to
that inflicting a horrendous amount of damage
to his face still despite bleeding profusely Ryan
to make sure to tell junichi that Maki has indeed
become just like toji however unlike toji who
never decided to destroy the entire clan on a
whim Mahi will do that if she is not killed here
and now junichi attacks Marky and launches a huge
number of cursed energy propelled fists running
down from the sky at her this pummels everything
and the immediate area which causes ranta to
believe they actually succeeded at his final
moments rancid then collapses on his knees while
they smile thinking they won and succumbs to the
previous strain of his injuries while Maki the
complete and utter God walks out of the dust
and smoke with janichi's head hanging from her
fist finally the misogynistic neoyazinen who
secondly under being an absolute hoe as the
head of the hay Squad confronts Marky via a
small traditional japanese-style bridge that
extends over a nice Pond standing there he
of all people calls Marky crawl and asks if she
even has a human heart to which Marky will they
cold and callous face replies no as your heart
has already been taken from her skipping into a
flashback join aoya's childhood we find that he's
always been wrapped in Cotton wool and constantly
praised by his family members he was recognized
as a genius and many always believed he would grow
into the head of the clan after naobito love how
Mega me just showed up on the block out of nowhere
and messed up that entire plan for him anyways
anyways now you heard of a black sheep any Clan
who didn't have any cursed energy and went to see
how pitiful that person was however after seeing
him Naomi was physically shaken upon seeing toji's
Cold Yet unconsumed eyes back in reality now nalia
initiates the fight quickly sending a series of
Rapid punches towards her however Marky is able
to Parry the majority of them or try and account
the number of movements in that singular moment
sadly while she's big braining his technique now
he interrupts it and grabs her causing her to be
frozen in Sonic frame then using the Extreme
Velocity his technique provides naioya kicks
Maki through several stone structures surrounding
the area now you're standing there thinking he is
the top G as adamant to himself that Marquis is
not toji regardless of a new Boost in power yes
she ain't even at the same power level yet bro
she just unlocked the full extent of her Heavenly
restriction like Goku wasn't all of a sudden
Super Saiyan 3 when he unlocked Super Saiyan 1
like it's not how it works you've got you've still
gotta train and build time you know anyways now
you thinks that the sin of insignificant people
is the ignorance of strength everyone misjudged
toji because of his lack of cursed energy and
naillou doesn't believe anyone other than Gojo
truly understood who he actually was using
his curse technique now he continually builds
up momentum and overwhelms Marky with one high
speed move after another being a mess of toji in
goju Fanboy now he desires to prove that he is
the only one who will stand with him as one of
the strongest not Marquee even with her improved
abilities Marky is starting to get hurt by narious
attacks and struggles to keep up admitting that
this situation is getting bad for neoya and like
in his fight with choso he won't stop building
up speed this time he understands that strength
equals weight and speed and plans to pierce Marty
at Max velocity having already gone supersonic
Mikey gained a steel body that is broken away
from cursed energy in exchange for Maya's life
she welcomes a head-on collision and takes the
stance of the shiranui Garter which for all of
my Japanese lovers out there is a specific form
that sumo wrestlers take Marquis attempts to take
on the brunt of now your supersonic speed in order
to stop his movements even if it means sacrificing
ropes appearing to stay through maki's defensive
strategy now he attacks her with his palm in doing
so it forces Maki to follow the 24 frames per
second roll of projection sorcery failure to do so
means being frozen inside a frame for one second
like what just happened with her previously when
she was kicked across the yard still moving at
top speed and seeing his adversary as nothing more
than an imposter Neo believes Maki is frozen and
prepares to finish her off however Maki actually
isn't even phased by his technique and is even
obeying the specific 24-frame rule of it now being
able to move fast enough Mikey turns around and
counter attacks and accepting the area's path with
her first now your attempts to call Monkey a fake
but before he finishes she smashes his face into
the ground with a monstrous punch that ends the
fight and he forms now your skull now acting like
the absolute boss she is she looks down on her
pathetic bloody cousin and asks him to repeat that
so I guess all of the action in regards to the
Xenon Clan mutilation ends there but we still have
just one more massive moments I probably should
Chuck in here for all of you guys because I oh my
Lord it wraps everything up just perfectly having
Lefty Battlefield now Marky finds her mother in a
kitchen area like of course like where else would
she be and he's dead in the household it's just
so so freaking sex to stop them marky's mother
tells you to stay back but Maki wants to know why
she screamed at her to come back earlier in the
corridor to destroy to even recall what happened
only moments prior mucky's mother can only ask
what Maki is talking about dissatisfied Marquee
approaches her mother who yells out in panic
several times before a blood is splattered on
the wall okay I'm not gonna lie this does confuse
me a slight bird I think Mumsy twin the blade on
herself right here but honestly let me know
what you guys think down below I really don't
think Marky actually sliced up her mum outside
throughout and around the estate the hay and
the kokoru squads have been completely decimated
with their corpses lining the area somehow like
the cockroach she is nailya heavily injured but
still somehow barely alive walks around pouring
blood from his face until he finally collapses
through a door onto the ground inside he mocks
Marky for not ending him and leaving him like this
when out of freaking nowhere marky's mother walks
up behind him with her throat already slits and
bleeding so she's definitely approaching death
for sure but still somehow holding the kitchen
knife difficult is in an estate like thing nail
you who's currently too pitiful to even protect
himself then there's probably the woman he hated
the most the mother of Marky and Mai stab him
through the back with a goddamn kitchen knife
which by the way is something that this [__]
said should happen to any female who is weaker
than any man so like oh my God you've got to
chill out with him sneaky little like four
Shadow Wings here and there now it calls her
a piece of trash by either way ends up dying
a pitiful death with a woman laying on top of him
unable to do anything about it on top and fading
away the girl's mother admits that she really was
was glad to have given birth to two amazing girls
after absolutely ruining the entire student family
tree Mahi exits the property with Maya's body Mama
arrives just moments later having been chasing
behind Maya and concern seeing now that Mai has
died as a result of not being there to help Momo
cries and sobs over her regrets silently Mikey
hands over Mai's body to which Momo asks Marquee
what she's going to do now but our girl still
obviously shaken remains completely silent as she
walks away with a blade in her hand later on it is
explained that these inning clan members who were
not even prison at the estate that day also died
violent deaths Mucky literally hunted them all
down in one day and killed them all it's crazy no
residuals were found other than Trace Amounts from
a cursed tool skipping back now to the moments
before leaving tingen yujin migami were given the
third and final third Year's location that being
the gambling madman Hikari Kenji it is explained
that Hikari is currently just chilling out while
being suspended and makes money as a bookie
for an underground fighting Club the spread
pit level Fight Club puts Sorcerers against one
another in hand-to-hand combats these Spectators
are mostly non-sorcerers which just goes to show
that hakari literally doesn't care about the Jutsu
regulations now arriving at a parking garage the
two Sorcerers removed the Jujutsu uniforms in an
attempt to try and trick Hikari into thinking
they aren't associated with the school Mega me
goes on to say that he may not associate with
him if he realizes they're also students from
jujutsutic it's a great area for them but to
Hikari they might as well be with the higher-ups
if he finds out who they truly are Yuji wonders
though if akari will actually help twitch Mega
me is unsure regardless of the situation though
they need his strength for the culling game and
will do their best to recruit him mikimi and Yuji
walk into the entrance of the parking garage in
a myth by two men the security guard look and do
tells the kids to get lost and instantly throws a
strong hook at Mega me however it stops just short
right before hitting his face as the security
guard slowly who's back his first he tells Mega
me that the one rule of the fight Club is that
nobody is supposed to say anything about the club
he demands to know who told them and threatens to
beat him up after finding out I honestly love
this whole idea with like Hikari being like a
Brad Pitt type character having this fight club
and everything it makes me feel like gigay is a
part of the generation that I grew up as a part
of and watch these movies while I was growing
up and just really enjoy them and everything and
now we're getting to see you know like his little
enjoyments from Western culture plopped right into
his story here which is absolutely fantastic Mega
me claims not to have gotten the person's name
before he killed them himself it was a cocky
sorcerer that disappeared about a month ago to
which the guy recalls some dude who disappeared
about a month ago but is unable to verify who
it was exactly mikumi asks to take his place
instead and threatens to murf The Bodyguard if he
refuses the manager then gives him message from
the boss to add an additional fighter to today's
tournament however only on the condition that Yuji
is selected as the fighter knowing that Yuji is
perfect for the job making me keeps up his act
and asks that he fight instead that it explains
to make me though that the boss doesn't like him
and refuses to let some fights to watch migami
having noticed all of the cameras around him
decides to happily accept the invitation dude
is out playing like some 4D level chest trying
to trick everyone including Yuji at the moment
like yuji's probably just standing there utterly
confused after leaving and confirming that akari
must have been observing them through the cameras
they go over the plan firstly your tears to look
for and make contact with a carry on the inside
while Megami attempts to sneak in the parking
garage from outside obviously this is hella
risky because if they discover Mega me sneaking
around they will probably instantly distrust
ug so if they are discovered they decide to
use Force to make their way through to Hikari
but only as a final Resort even though the best
course of action would be to let Yuji do his thing
first tsukumi's deadline is fast approaching which
causes megamek to get a bit recluse it's currently
5 PM on the 10th of November leaving the group
nine days to rescue sakumi before the deadline
closes that evening Yuji returns to the parking
garage for the fight the man there preps Yuji by
explaining the details of how the tournament works
there are only two rules no retreating and no
Jujutsu which obviously piguji is completely fine
with as the dude was first and foremost a physical
Beast anyways anyways now heading down the stairs
towards the arena Yuji asks the dude what the boss
is like to what she says to Yuji that he can only
find out if he actually meets him he then explains
that there are two types of matches scripted and
unscripted ones these so-called scripted matches
are actually script written by the boss and the
Fuji is able to put on a show in an unscripted
fight it will likely get his attention possibly
resulting in some kind of Mace hanging arriving
at the arena now which is like this dopa section
of the garage where the Upper Floor has been
almost entirely renovated into an area that allows
Spectators to view from above Yuji is introduced
to his opponent and someone that I can 100 say
surprise is absolutely like everyone here even
rereading the section I forgot this Beast made
his appearance here with that good old fighter
announce a voice the infamous John Bobby Begins
the tournament by introducing the newcomer itadori
against no one other than Panda and in monitoring
room somewhere nearby chilling like the absolute
King he is Hikari says with his associate as the
fight begins he expresses his displeasure as he
believes things are starting to cool off Hikari
doesn't believe there is any fun in knowing who's
going to win an unscripted fight he doesn't think
anyone will be able to defeat Panda and is barely
watching however the lovely lady with him points
his attention over to the television we Eugene
is absolutely pummeling panda in spectacular
fashion by the way for those wondering like the
comet says just above I'm pretty sure Hikari and
Panda obviously know each other and are probably
extremely well on that like classmate level type
beat or friendship back in the fight Eugene panda
work together to put on a show that entertains
everyone watching in fact the fight is so damn
good it impresses even the goat himself John
freak and Bobby who screams that this is the
best fight he's ever seen while the two trade
blows Eugene Panda have a cheeky conversation
to exchange info Panda has been allowed into the
fight club but akari and the other cute third year
with him are actively avoiding Panda as well after
finishing their small conversation and agreeing to
end the fights Yuki lands a powerful fake body
shot that Panda sells with a way over the top
reaction to convince everyone that he's being
defeated big Bobby announces Yuji as the winner
leaving a lasting impression on everyone watching
even akari upstairs and has little content box
admits that he's impressed with yuji's ability to
fight in three dimensions while still dazzling the
spectacles he calls one of his managers and gets
him to bring Yuji up to his office he wants to
strike a deal with him while the iron is hot and
right scrubs for yuji's future fights this chick
chilly nearby who turns out to be be another of
Jiu Jitsu High's third years called Carrara Hoshi
tells akari that it all just sounds boring to her
elsewhere at the same time Mega me like the slimo
for years uses a deuce Shadow to eavesdrop on
the conversation without being seen he manually
phone asks Sakari what to do about the other brat
referring to Meek me who's like right behind him
to what shikari says he plans to have Carrara
keep an eye on him after leaving the area Panda
finds Megami in a nearby Forest he asks Megami
if he thinks that Yuji will be able to contact
takari to which Mega me thinks that he will but
asks Panda why he actually hasn't seen Hikari
himself Panda knows where Hikari is and says that
he's in the monitoring room on the roof but can't
get close to the door because of the Hoshi girls
curse technique it doesn't matter what he seems
to do walk or run he cannot approach the door
Mickey asks if it's only active when Carrara is
in the monitoring room but panda is unsure since
she's always with akari rather than forcing the
issue panda affected Spectators to avoid getting
on akari's bad side he goes on to say that he
thinks yuji's charm will work on akari but is also
apprehensive because Yuji is an extremely bad liar
as we all know from literally every time this
dude has had to lie about like anything so in
an attempt to save his ass Panda gave him some
tips beforehand just in case something random
happens worst case scenario would be for Hikari to
discover Yuji as which is you too high and boost
him out Panda wants to secure the area and monitor
the door to prevent this meaning that they'll need
to murk a few of the fodder security guards to
get up there he knows where all the cameras are
and their blind spots as well as their positions
of all of their lockouts Mega me acknowledges
that they might have a solid plan but carrara's
technique remains a random factor in everything
that they do so if akari and Carrara do end up
getting Yuji outside the door Mickey says that
they'll just have to give up on their objective
altogether later on and after winning another
match in the fight club Yuki sin's Mega me a text
at 12 58 saying that his meeting with akari at 1pm
while each of the five Lookouts maintain their
positions Carrara nicknames him you and shares
that Hikari had to repeat a year in junior high
Judy notes how cheerful Carrara is to which she
replies it's because akari is starting to feel
hot again having received the text making me
snakes into the first guard's Shadow and mounts
him from behind he chokes the man unconscious
tapes his mouth and zip ties his hands together
all done extremely quickly the second guard then
walks in without noticing a single thing as
immerse Megami quickly slides into his shadow
then continuing on the UFC style takedowns he
knocks him out with a perfect triangle choke at
the same time two other gods notice Panda playing
with a tire initially confused one of them wonders
if he eats fish sausage while the other recognizes
Panda from the tournament suddenly Panda switches
on them and knocks them both out before taking
the sausage then hitting up the emergency stairs
panda regroups with migami on the roof and moves
with him to guard the monitoring room door when
suddenly and unexpectedly Ferrara walks out of
the room just below them for a moment Mega me and
Panda just stand there completely stunned looking
up Carrara quickly notices the pier and instantly
makes a connection that Mega me and you are both
from Jujutsu high like Panda Carrara believing
that herkari is in danger reaches through her
phone and tries to contact him however mikami
summons his base of the shikigami the Divine
dog totality to try and stop her the shikigami
rushes Carrara and tries to restrain her but it
sent flying back into Mega me having dropped her
phone Carrara runs towards a monitoring room while
Panda who's kind of just standing there tries to
explain that they're not enemies Carrara doesn't
believe that they have a simple request for Hikari
and is upset with him for simply betraying them
due to carrara's technique holding Panda back
Mega me orders has a Divine dog to intercept her
path this instantly stops her but migami is also
suddenly pulled towards the shikagami he realizes
that in addition to being unable to reach Carrara
he is now unable to even separate from his Divine
dog while he thinks about how this first technique
Works neither he nor Panda have noticed a small
random star symbol on Panda's ass that reads star
am I like all my Lord bring back Professor diavolo
from the one punch man video we've got some space
facts here boys so Amai is actually a star in the
Milky Way and Maya is also like the traditional
name of the star known as Delta cruxes it is
visible from Earth and is only 364 light years
away or if you want that in miles it's about 2.139
quadrillion miles away anyways meanwhile inside of
the monitoring room Hikari the final special grade
student finally meets with Yuji for the first time
and typical Jujutsu cars in fashion akari had
some other bizarre but intriguing question he
asks Yuji would you believe me if I said you could
work for one hour a day and make 1 million yen a
month unsure as anyone would be in the situation
Yuji just blankly stays back in confusion confused
Yuki asks what he would need to do but akari says
he would have to pay 200 000 Yen obviously like a
cheeky Guru scam right here but you know what
I like a lot more than materialistic things
knowledge the more you learn the more you earn
you know I read a book a day not to show off it's
again about knowledge in fact something happened
that changed my life I bumped into a mentor like
yeah okay dude totally I'm sure that's how it
actually works even Yuji out of everyone doesn't
agree as he thinks that this one just feels kind
of shady Hikari agrees and points out that it's
a classic con with get rich quick scammers sell
turps it's an obvious scam but akari notes that
there are still a lot of people who will fall for
it and adds it up to something that he calls the
fever Hikari explains they're both the scammer
and the scammed are in a favor to change their
lives people get high on the fever and make stupid
decisions yet without it people can never fall in
love akari loves the fever and asks Yuji if he
knows the most direct way of engaging with it
dude Curry is such a such a tricky character to
get around and like write and stuff Yuji kisses
correctly and says that it's gambling I find this
like part absolutely hilarious but apparently
lots of girls dumped a curry in the past due to
his constant gambling but guys want to points
out that life itself is actually a gamble Society
tramples on losers who don't know when to quit but
akari points out that everyone gambles what people
truly hate is losing a character goes on to say
that he wants to control the fever of the entire
country using his fight club which is really like
the Fight Club movie if you think about it like
hikari's character in general is rarely playing
on that Brad Pitt side of uh the main character's
brain and everything he's going for that like I
want to change the entire world Prospect or like
the entire world feeling he says that he wants to
take advantage of the current chaos and expand
his business making the Jujutsu headquarters
aware of his Ambitions needing strong allies for
this he asks Yuji if he wants to get high on his
fever Yuji prepares to ask for help when all of a
sudden they're interrupted by a phone call which
completely changes the atmosphere after it ends
he offers Yuji a drink which he refuses because
of his age hearing this he brings up out of the
blue that started Gojo can't drink either Juju
pretends not to know who Gojo is but akari who
finds a suspicious finishes his drink and asks
if Yuji is a spy from Juju to take before Yuji can
speak up to Defenders case akari tosses the drink
glass right at his face Yugi deflects the cup
but akari quickly activates his curse technique
summoning two tall sliding doors that attempt to
close YouTube between them Yuji jumps above the
horizontal doors and tries to speak up but akari
continues his attack trapping him with his doors
and kicking him in the face while revealing
that a call from Carrara means something bad
has happened Yoji recalls what megumi said about
only asking for cooperation and hit but zakari in
an attempt to get him to listen however the third
year doesn't give up and refuses because now his
fever is running cold meanwhile outside the room
Carrara is in a deadlock with panda and mega me
since they are stuck making me tries to explain
that they're not on the Jujutsu high side side
and they need hikari's help but Carrara just
doesn't listen confused as to what happened
between them and the higher-ups panda explains to
mikami that conservative members of the community
prefer traditional Jujutsu while akari has
Blended hers for technology so just think
of the moment during the shipuya incident where
mimiko and nanako got absolutely murked by sukuna
and he was like oh a curse camera technique
cool that was a blended technique as it had
been like blended with the camera and the cell
phone Carrara points out they're just you too
high lost because they have their priorities
backwards but adds that they always have Gojo
to clean up their messes so why are they even
here asking for help me give me reveals to her
that satello Gojo was sealed during shabuya but
Carrara makes a face of comic disbelief as she
obviously just can't believe that that could ever
happen realizing this Megami decides to activate
his rabbit Escape summoning dozens of his rabbit
shikigami as a large swarm of rabbit shikigami
cover the roof he notices that each of the rabbits
are marked with a symbol saying a Crux none of the
robots can actually get near the monitor room
where migami notices another symbol starget Crux
has been placed the rabbits quickly spread across
the entire roof so that migami can see where and
where they can't go seeing this Carrero repels
them but is still confused at the whole point of
it carrara's innate technique Mark shukigami the
same as Sorcerers so just like with the Divine
dog Carrara believes that Mega me will attract
all of the rabbits and suffocate inside of them
however he suddenly dispels them all Megami asks
Panda however Escape was to which Panda confirms
that the shukigami were attracted to him and the
second floor but they couldn't reach Carrara or
the monitor room to war pen finally figures out
that he has been marked with his symbol Amai and
mega me has been marked with a Crux Megami isn't
sure what's going on but he knows that carrara's
curse technique is very likely based on the
constellation of stars Rara notices that Mega
me is figuring out how her technique works and
puts her attention on her Mega me turns to Carrara
and says that it might be based on the Southern
Cross constellation Carrara is surprised that he
gets correctly but gives it away that he got it
correct with a reaction which continues to add
to her frustration Chrono said if migami continues
to figure out how the technique works then it'll
eventually reach the monitor room Kara resolves
to hold him off and try to prevent that no matter
what Megami thanks tsukumi for teaching him about
the Southern Cross but is still confused because
he knows it should have four specific points Mega
Million Panda get close to one another and discuss
carrara's curse technique he initially thought
that it assigned them each a point on the Southern
Cross to maintain distance between each point
however this can't be the case because Carrara
can approach the door and mega me can approach
Panda making me realizes that it's more likely
that the acoustic Nick has a determined route
where there is a sequential order for who can
go near what depending on what point they've been
marked worth Panda considers that the technique
doesn't affect the yozer the mega me debunks this
because the Divine dog totality couldn't approach
Carrara earlier of Carrara and the door both hit
stars that repel Megami and Panda then Carrara
could simply flee Mickey being Panda surmised
that this must mean the Southern Cross has five
or more points as if there were only four stars
one of them should be able to approach the enemy
sorcerer since that isn't the case here there must
be a first star between them that they must go
through in order to reach her and the door Panda
asks what they should do if there are six or seven
points but migami says five is already too many
to make sense for a cross obviously though if you
live in like NZ or Australia or even pretty much
anywhere in the southern hemisphere you know for a
fact that there are actually indeed five stars in
the Southern Cross anyway anyway knowing that she
might be foiled soon Carrara goes on the offensive
she ferociously jumps on the hood of the car and
marks it with himai sending it flying up at Panda
the car flips into Panda but he manages to catch
it and assures Mega me that he's okay one megaby
runs away Panda tosses the car away from him to
what's making me concerned reminds Panda not to
throw the car away or else the Mark will simply
Attract it back to him and as he says this the
car comes shooting right back at Panda slamming
to rexley into his head while sprinting they give
me surmises that contact needs to be made by the
user to place a star Carrara marked migami by
marking his curse energy through his Divine dog
in order to Mark more objects like the monitor
room door or the car they need to be charged
beforehand while someone else's cursed to energy
honestly Mega Meat is just so freaking big brain
right now have he had the raw strength of Eugene
dude would actually like be pure Insanity anyways
anyways Mega me focuses on seeing the curse energy
residuals on the car and find some from someone
other than Carrara continuing with his theory
Mega me assumes the technique doesn't have a
long range and eventually finds a parking stop
marked with a fifth star Mimosa Mega me quickly
touches the parking stop and doesn't notice any
more residuals he knows carrara's curse energy is
already marked with a star so he assumes they
can't use the curse technique to Mark another
object with a Crux and attract more objects
to him however to me give me shock a bunch of
objects marked with the Crux are already heading
directly for him finally it is explained that
carrara's curse technique love Rendezvous marks
five stars with a Southern Cross motive to Target
curse energy for one star to approach another
it must follow a determined order or else one
of the targets for the same star will attract
dirt the order follows the stars from nearest
furthest on a diagram constellations come across
as flat but space is actually a three-dimensional
area and each star is a different distance from
Earth migami was marked with a Crux so you must
travel through mimosa and Ganan in order to reach
the Crux or in my monkey brain speak he has to go
through the parking stop Mark then Carrara and
finally he can make it to the monitoring door
anyways anyways cryo admits she's impressed that
migami figured out how her technique works that
being said prayer believes Megami was too quick
to conclude that more objects couldn't be thrown
at him while Carrara can't Mark more than one
star with the same icon she can simply remove the
monitor room door marker and Mark other things
with migami's motoff instead suddenly Harare
is called off guard when the Divine dog randomly
reappears behind her megamese jacked up shikigami
quickly immobilizes Carrara confusing her until
she comes to the realization that Mega me never
dispelled it instead he was able to guess which
one would attract the other and maneuver so there
was a wall between them then after waiting for a
while he unjammed the Divine dog from the wall so
he could take advantage of the fact that Carrara
was now approachable with Carrara now stuck it
forces her to release the love Rendezvous making
me quickly restrains Carrara so that she doesn't
run away but simply asks her to listen to what he
has to say he then dispels his Divine dog totality
or simply asking her to listen still skeptical
crowd doesn't think Miami could have known
whether he or the shukigami would have been pulled
Mega me and met said he took a gamble but now he
knows that the one with the higher curse energy
output does the attracting initially the Divine
dog pulled Mega me but the opposite occurred when
Mega me reinforced his body with cursed energy
we can be the inlets Carrera go and begs her to
listen because he's frankly just no time confuses
to why he would release her Carrara decides to
believe him however the monitor room door has
suddenly seen flying off its hinges with Yuji
bursting out migami quickly realizes that Yuji
has been head outside the room and right on cue
the fighting theme Hikari walks outside visibly
irritated with the whole situation Fuji tells
Mega me and Panda to stay out of it prompting her
character believe that he's being underestimated
he immediately throws a devastating punch that
smashes yuji's face and sends him flipping across
the roof Hikari eventually notices that Yuji isn't
even resisting and in that moment the first
year Springs back to his feet standing there
Yuji spurts blood out of his nose while akari
is just blown away no team that his adversary
doesn't even intend to dodge to him yuji's lack
of resistance all but confirms he's not a spy so
akari says they'll hear Yuji out on the condition
that he can remain standing and flew is up as
curse energy Carrara urges him to listen but akari
claims that he just said he would before asking
Yuji why he's asking him for help specifically
Yuji says that all of his seniors have confirmed
Hikari as strong annoying him akari punches Yuji
again and while he's railing through the air
usually compares to Carry's reinforced punches
to getting hurt with a serrated bat which like
oh my Lord the cheese grater level of curse energy
right here irritated Curry yells at Yuji stating
that Sorcerers understand asking one another for a
favor is equal to asking someone to put their life
on the line in order for her character takes such
a risk he needs Yuji to prove here and now that he
has the fever to convince some Yuji claims that he
doesn't have a fever and is just a cog a cognitive
machine that Sorcerers need to eliminate curse
Spirits typical depresso Yuji right here like
even akari finds his answer extremely boring so he
decides to wind up another punch prompting mikami
to express his concern akari strikes Yuji with the
hardest blow yet line across the roof into a wall
and appearing to finally knock him out Hikari
begins to tell them to leave but Yuji suddenly
reappears behind him Hikari is genuinely surprised
and backs up wondering how he's still standing
after suffering three literally mind-altering
blows he asks Yuji what he is to what she replies
while the same answer is before he believes His
function is getting rid of curses and since Kari
isn't necessary for that Yuji decides he won't
stop until he agrees Yuji think it's Up All In
A Curry's face and asks him what his function is
Hikari who still surprised asks himself if this is
the look of a cog in fever he goes to punch Yuji
once again but finally Carrara interrupts and
manages to get hikari's attention she asks Sakari
a Fuji's fever is burning hot enough for him yet
standing near he recognizes that carrara's point
is undeniable acknowledging that it is indeed true
he then suddenly agrees to hear Yuji out and tells
me give me and Panda the that he's willing to cut
a deal honestly if you're confused as to what
happened don't worry because Mickey and Panda
are like just as confused as everyone else as to
what's just happened he asks Carrara if what they
said convinced them to watch she confirms skipping
forward akari finally sits down and listens to
what they've got to say he's completely surprised
to hear that Gojo was sealed and Panda adds that
masamichi also died and they fight with kakuganji
recently after Shibuya obviously this is like the
first that they've all heard of Jagger's death as
well Eugene mikami a concern for panda santiaga
was pretty much his dad Hikari expresses that he's
bummed out now that everyone who's ever taken care
of him is out of the picture honestly I think
like as in everyone he was probably referring to
Yaga Gojo nanami and like maybe even ghetto from
the school as well before he passed away Hikari
agrees to help combat the culling game however he
tells him to not get the wrong idea and makes it
a point that everyone understands that this is
a deal and that they must return the favor at
some point in the future and want to know more and
asks what exactly he desires but making me Cuts in
and comments that he doesn't think whatever it is
will be difficult which annoys akari Hikari calls
Megami a sea urchin head or a [__] pretty much
and asks him what he could possibly know probably
mega mega flicks on him saying that he's literally
the head of his hidden Clan who starts off and is
like no I don't want the role Marquee like maybe
you should have her and now he's flexing on Hikari
right here shocked Hikari finds us even more of
a surprise than the news about Gojo and Yaga he
believes that with the backing of The Big Three
Families making revisions to society will be easy
however the funny part about this is that like
I just talked about earlier in the video Mahi
actually destroys the entire sitting Clan the next
day so her fight and all of that with Maya dying
Etc happens after this point so I don't know
why Giga decided to write this backwards here
maybe he just thought of it afterwards and
thought he'd throw that in just to add a bit
more like confusion of the story so thank you
very much Keke with everyone in agreement Yuji
states that they need to decide what colony to
go to when suddenly cocaine remember like the
game interface thingy that was explained right
at the beginning of the arc appears above Yuji
and makes a loud ringing noise cocaine announces
that one player has added a new rule to the game
allowing players to have access to information
on other players this information includes their
name number of points number of rules added and
their current Colony this rule was added by a
new mysterious looking dude named Hajime kashimo
a sorcerer who's over 400 years old no sakuna and
is currently dominating the entirety of Tokyo's
number two Colony after making the announcement
kogane introduces itself to Yuji its voice
differs to that of the announcements because
now it's acting as liaison for the Cullen game
assigned to Yuji instead of the announcers Megami
doesn't understand why Yuji has already been
considered as a player before entering a colony
which is actually super interesting and I'd love
to like know what you guys think it could be but
like Yuji I believe it has something to do with
sukona and most likely the fact that sakuna was
a cursed object linked to kinjaku in some kind of
way Megami points out that that's still strange
because Yuji and Jester sukuna's fingers of his
own will unlike the past Sorcerers who were in
contracts with kinjaku so yeah there definitely
is something else going on what if perhaps it
was actually the valve sakuna made with Yuji you
know the one that he doesn't actually remember
currently even happened just an idea Yuji hisco
game show him his own player info amigami uses
the list to fight kashimo identifying them as the
one who added the rule Megami believes that they
can get through the culling game without killing
anyone by forcing someone with enough points to
add another role the two players that already fit
their bill are G makashimo and heromi hikaruma in
order to save sakumi the first rule they have to
add will need to offset rule eight Megami states
that they can do so by adding a rule that allows
players to transfer points between each other
after aiding that rule Megami suggests adding
another one that allows players to spin points
to remove themselves from the game entirely to
which Hikari points out that that might actually
conflict with the long lasting rules of the game
but Mega me figures that maybe it'll work under
the right conditions but ultimately it's up to the
game master and regardless the team now has a plan
while they look for the sorcerer known as Angel
they will also search for Hajime and hegaruma
then attempt to take them down for their points
so that officially brings us to the very end of
what is Juju Kaiser's perfect preparation Arc
and obviously this Arc in general is absolutely
massive in terms of just the information that
gets given to us in regards to the culling game
which is going to be going on in the next Arc
finally so we are actually going to be getting
into that along with like all of the fights there
and you know like just marky's Massacre and like
who destroying her entire clan in general leaving
only her and migami as a part of the zening clan
or like I guess Xenon and fushiguro clans lift
you know that's all that's left over from the
clan and technically Mega me is the head of a
headless Clan like I said right at the end of
the video there with you know Hikari and you know
like finally we were actually introduced to Hikari
here which is an absolutely dope character I never
expected him to be such an interesting character
and most likely based off like a brad pitt-esque
type character from you know like their entire
fight club scene especially with his entire Fight
Club and wanting to change you know like the Jiu
Jitsu of society it felt that way to me at least
anyway obviously if you guys have enjoyed this
video and want to see more stuff just like it in
the future then make sure you hit the Subscribe
button and also so be sure to leave a like on
the video as it really helps out with pushing
my stuff to a bunch of new amazing people and
of course we are like almost at 100K Subs we're
only 9k away now which is like freaking amazing
so if you do watch all my videos and stuff then
do make sure to hit that subscribe button and
smash the you know like the Bell alert so that
you do get all my videos when they first
you know releasing everything but anyway
for now it's been your professional degenerate
dear Volo and I will see you all in a bit bye